formidable ces nouveaux savoirs barde ça
le blaireau y'a que ça de vrai pour bien
attendez à la peau
bonjour vous étiez là excusez moi j'ai
eu tellement de travail aujourd'hui que
j'ai pas eu le temps de me raser avant
votre arrivée télé suivez moi jusqu'au
kiosque et de julie
julie s'il te plaît puisque tu fais avec
de la mousse à raser sur la figure mais
je me rase évidemment à cette heure
merci du renseignement et nos amis
viennent d'arriver je voudrais que tu
leur tiennent compagnie je vais finir de
bras ses
excuses
je suis en train de préparer mon dessert
favori une mousse au citron alors si
vous voulez bien que je vais vous
expliquer comment la faire c'est très
simple d'ailleurs vous allez voir si ça
vous plaît vous la ferez chez vous comme
ça alors
tout d'abord il faut 3 e
trois petits suisses une tasse de sucre
en poudre et à citron
on sait par les blancs des jaunes
on bat les blancs en neige on met les
jaunes dans une autre charte à laquelle
on ajoute le sucre en poudre
le jus du citron
[Musique]
le zeste du citron qu'on a rappé avants
et les trois petits suisses
voilà après on mélange bien
et à la fin nous rajoute
les blancs battus en neige c'est simple
à alors vous vous souviendrez bien trois
petits suisses 3e ainsi trop et une
tasse de sucre en poudre
voilà et j'en rajoute le blancs battus
en neige après vous le mettez dans des
coupes et ses coupes vous les mettez au
réfrigérateur pendant quelques heures
pour qu'elles soient bien pris
ouais je lis je me suis rasé je me suis
rasé de près d'un peu trop près même
bah oui je me suis coupé c'est ta faute
si faute de bien sûr tout à l'heure du
midi du mahdi de nous dépêcher dumas
fait des reproches je me suis pressé
effectivement et voilà le résultat je
suis désolé on pourra visiter pas très
juridique écoute pour te consoler tu vas
pouvoir déguster dans très peu de temps
une lisse au citron que je viens de
confusion des sentiments diras des
nouvelles ça c'est trop on se la mettre
quelques heures au réfrigérateur
formidable julie en attendant je peux
t'emprunter compagnie fourre tout
je vais faire un jeu avec les enfants
tout à l'heure les enfants ils ont
emmené venez vite nous allons faire un
jeu met tous on va s'asseoir sur le banc
les enfants je vais vous montrer un
certain nombre d'objets et vous allez me
dire s'ils servent ou non à faire de la
pâtisserie d'accord
premier objet peut-on faire de la
pâtisserie avec cet objet north marquait
ce que je sais c'est que je voudrais
voir comment de je viens de là pour
faire de la chimie oui ça s'appelle une
cornu alors donc ça ne sert pas faire de
la pâtisserie ceci
tu as raison le tapioca la soul le sucre
le riz etc etc ça c'est l'enfer la
pâtisserie oui oui
ensuite
ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est paris ça
sert oui interne à pâtisserie oui
ceci
c'est un moule c'est un moule qui sert à
faire hélas la balise laert d'état donc
ça sert à faire de la pâtisserie je mets
de côté ce site
très bien très bonnes réponses
incite ainsi trop poreux tournante du
goût pour fête du goût là dans les
habitudes
dans une tarte au citron par exemple tu
as raison donc on s'en sert pour faire
de la pâtisserie ceux ci ont éliminé les
vélib est intacte et 12 heures mais pas
de pâtes les pommes de terre ne les
pommes de terre c'est pas de la
pâtisserie mais on peut hélas on peut
remuer la le jeu et l'impact
donc on peut s'en servir
ceci non
c'est une râpe à boire donc
l'effet minimes on appelle ça une lime
unis mais c'est aussi une râpe et ça ça
où ça sort pas faire de la pâtisserie ça
sympa ceci dit monfils ce sont des
fruits confits y ça sert pour la
pâtisserie oui ça sert surtout pour la
décoration bien je vais vous confier un
secret julie est en train de nous
préparer une mousse au citron
on va l'attendre à la déguster
apparemment par mon arme bonjour tout le
monde
si vous saviez comme je suis à chaque
fois que j'arrive dans ce jardin je suis
toujours certains de rencontrer des amis
merveilleux
bonjour julie lescaut casimir nous
qu'est ce que vous mangez là ça a l'air
très bon qu'est ce que c'est c'est nous
ce qui prouve bien préparée par julie
jornet l'eau à la bouche
oui ma part
je suis désolé casimir mais justement je
viens de m'apercevoir que j'ai toutes
tribus et comment tu n'as même pas mis
les trois-quarts de côté pour moi abbas
est charmant
casimir tu sais tu veux partager avec
moi
merci je ne mange pas les restes mois
tant pis au revoir
à ses jours
le pauvre on n'a pourtant pas fait
exprès que
quel culot alors j'en ai les jambes
coupées enfin c'est une façon de parler
parce que si j'avais vraiment les jambes
coupées je ne pourrais pas marché
de toute façon j'en aurai pas voulu de
leur mousse au citron si c'est quelque
chose d'un beaucoup trop léger pour moi
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
mais c'est qu'un bol de mousse au citron
ils ont voulu me faire une farce ils ont
caché la fin ils sont à ressort mais
vraiment gentil quand même je vais me
régaler avec cette mousse au citron
bravo juillet c'était formidable
commence est en outre ça n'est vraiment
pas dangereux il n'y a pas de fourneaux
allumé pour la préparer torres est
formidable merci pour ta mousse au
citron moi je vais ranger mes affaires
de toilette
excuse-moi casimir et voudrais tu te
pousser un petit peu merci
ça loeb il a disparu tu as perdu quelque
chose transforme oui mon bon bol de
mousse à raser je l'avais posé là tu
l'aurais pas vu
c'était de la mousse à raser
que veux tu dire par c'était rien juste
une question pourquoi parce qu'en disant
c'était tu emploies le ver d'être à
l'inter fait ce qui signifierait que la
mousse à raser n'existe plus tu as menée
sur casimir qu'as tu fait de ma mousse à
raser
je les mange et
taboo sarrazy mais oui j'étais persuadé
que c'était un symbole de mousse au
citron quand vous aviez caché mais quasi
même c'est épouvantable mais rien n'est
plus mauvais que que le savon à barbe
alors moi j'ai pas prouvé sa mort et du
court mon pauvre casimir du va sûrement
être malade tu crois vraiment c'est sûr
quand tu as raison françois je commence
à me sentir très bien mon jeu je crois
je ferais mieux d'aller me coucher
invite invasive est allongé casimir
julie et moi nous irons te rendre visite
photo josé janson boobies amont pour
qu'ils évitent pour la pâte reposer
mais si les balades dans peut-être et
nous allons la réveiller il faut les
voir c'est qassimi on n'a pas besoin
d'un médecin te va tout de même pas
déguiser en docteur barbiche ça le
docteur darby chaussée pour ryad mais si
casimir est malade il a besoin d'un
médecin allons-y ça m'ennuie le déranger
comme ça sans prévenir
rappelons le nous verrons bien très
bonne idée
casimir casimir ça va casimir
questions